so I'm notoriously disorganized when it
comes to money and paying bills and
personal finance in general I have no
good reason for it only to say that if
left to my own devices I'd only ever
read things and learn things and write
things and make videos like this in
respect to my greater happiness
the only value money has is to give me
the freedom to do the things I like in
itself money to me is worthless and
maybe that's the reason why I neglect it
so much because it's time-consuming and
tedious and boring and clerical I mean
just take a look at this take a look at
this let me show you this right here
perfect metaphor for what I'm talking
about
so here's a book of the philosophy of
Nietzsche I've just been catching up on
a little bit of Nietzsche as you do and
as a bookmark this is absolutely real we
have some Macy's bill geico bill here's
one here's a special one we got here
aha Wells Fargo ah yes the title to my
car check this out I mean is that a
system or what so today I've resolved to
build a system for myself to become more
organized in this regard and there's
only one place to go when you have a
problem like this but you didn't know
this when I staples was my first job I
worked
when I was a senior in high school for
six months I stole so many pins I don't
know if they're gonna let the it right
now
first item we need three-ring binder
what color do we like here what color
chartreuse perhaps item number two file
folders okay item number three we got
binder clips last item magnifying glass
just kidding one of these desperate
calculators so that you look really cool
and that people in the other rooms know
that you're deadly serious about finance
item four - sharpies okay make
three-ring binder holes in your folders
first step
yeah
okay so got all the bills for my debts
all the bills and other extra stuff
that's been mixing with it first thing
you're gonna do is take these folders
that I hole punch they twelve of them
that's look at that we're gonna write
every month of the year well folks get
it TS Eliot reference yeah you're
freaking out right now
about how cool I am
now take our folders marks with the
months and put them into the bike get a
Macy's bill here for April okay
so here's what we're gonna do the month
of April and take one of our binder
rings here dog thinks that these are
snacks and toys which you shouldn't feed
your dog binders binder clips if we
hadn't paid this Macy's bill the system
would be to stick to clip it to the back
of the envelope that means it's not paid
now once we do pay it and I just did pay
this I'm gonna throw it in the inside
and we're good to go
so we're gonna do that to all these
bills right now
okay so we're all done all the bills are
in here in the 2012 binder we got all
the paint bills in the folders and
what's not paid we've got attached to
the back to be sent in the mail look in
good organization item number five sixty
quarter coin referees just for the hell
of it aha
binder clips item number three fifteen
here that'll be just fine